Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin Leute! Windows Sound? Jawohl, passt. Es ist ja auch selten, dass das passt mit dem Windows Sound.
Meistens hat es irgendwas rumgestellt, ohne dass man halt wirklich was dran rumgestellt hat.
Äh, das wollte ich eigentlich jetzt gar nicht aufmachen. Keine Ahnung. Whatever.
Kann das aufhören, irgendwelche Sachen zu laden?
hat wohl er hat mir wohl mal irgendwie im stream einer geschickt oder so
als bisschen leiser müssen wir noch machen so irgendwie glaube so ist ganz
gut ja leute was geht aber was trinken
Ich hab seit 20 Jahren den gleichen Wassersprudler.
Und das Ding funzt immer noch.
Also das war mal was, was sich gelohnt hat.
Und das war ja auch nicht teuer damals, das Zeug.
Und ich hab auch immer noch die uralten Flaschen.
Auf der Flasche hier steht, glaube ich, die ist nur bis...
Die darf man nur bis 2005 oder so verwenden.
Steht hier irgendwo drauf.
nicht mehr verwenden nachricht ich sehe es gar nicht mehr aber irgendwas in der
richtung steht steht hier irgendwo drauf nicht nach 2006 steht hier drauf genau
nicht nach oktober 2006 verwenden
ja 20 jahre später geht immer noch ist sie aus plastik ja ja ja auf jeden fall
ist aus plastik ich weiß die neuen die neuen die haben auch die möglichkeit glasflaschen
zu verwenden aber ganz ehrlich dass das tut ganz gut
leute dann müssen wir jetzt erst einmal deine meinung zu cash ios sage ich dir gleich
Wir starten erstmal CacheOS, dass wir über CacheOS reden können.
Die können bersten und das Plastik fängt sich an zu zersetzen.
Ja.
Genau nach 20 Jahren hat sich schon alles zersetzt.
Ja, vielleicht...
Ihr habt gar nicht so unrecht.
Vielleicht soll ich mal wirklich neue Flaschen kaufen.
Du du du du du.
Du du du.
Auf.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
So.
Gucken wir mal.
Ob der das jetzt irgendwann nochmal hinkriegt.
Mit starten.
Jawoll.
Exzellent.
Moment.
Was ist hier los?
Warum?
Achso, weil der mal wieder die Logitech-Software nicht gestartet hat, oder?
Da weiß der teilweise nicht bei dem Krempel.
What the fuck?
Warum geht meine Logitech-Geschichte nicht?
Was ist da los?
Ja, ja.
Das sollte doch eigentlich...
Ja.
Geht doch.
Hä?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Also, dann kann ich mich dazu auslassen.
Das ist nämlich eine sehr gute Frage.
Ich verwende nämlich CacheOS jetzt selbst schon seit ein paar Monaten mit KDE.
Das heißt, was ich sage, erstreckt sich nur auf CacheOS mit KDE.
Und dazu kann ich sagen, ich finde es nice.
Also ich kann das empfehlen.
Es ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt das mit Abstand beste System für Linux-Einsteiger.
Das ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Also wenn man sich ein bisschen an Linux rantasten will, man darf nicht vergessen,
CacheOS ist immer noch ein Anstellungsunter der Haube.
Man muss aber relativ wenig wissen.
Es gibt aber trotzdem Sachen, die einfacher sind.
Warum es CacheOS heißt, ich habe keine Ahnung, warum es CacheOS heißt.
Vielleicht wegen irgendwelchen Kernels, Scheduler-Dingern oder so.
Keine Ahnung, warum es CacheOS heißt.
Was mir ganz gut gefällt bei CacheOS ist diese Geschichte hier, also unter anderem,
Ja, wenn du jetzt irgendwas installierst, sagt mal irgendwas, was kann ich denn, SL, irgendwas, hier, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt was installiere, dann, ich installiere jetzt mal was, dann macht der automatisch, zumindest wenn man BTFS verwendet, was standardmäßig, glaube ich, sogar mittlerweile ausgewählt ist, dann macht der automatisch einen Snapshot.
und wenn ich mir jetzt mein System zerschieße
und so, dass es nicht
mehr bootet, ne, Cache ist
nicht immutable, wenn ich mir jetzt mein System
zerschieße, so dass es nicht mehr bootet,
habe ich im Bootmenü,
also, ne, Bootmenü trifft sich wirklich
im Bootmanager,
also im Crap oder in
Limein oder wie das andere Ding heißt,
habe ich Auswahl der letzten
Snapshots und kann quasi
auf den Stand zurück, Bootloader,
ja, Bootloader, kann
auf den stand zurück bevor ich mit erschossen habe das ist richtig da ist ich finde das auch gut das
ist nicht kompliziert das sind das geht man bei anderen betriebssystem auch paar packages
nachher zählt aber ich finde es richtig gut dass das standardmäßig damit kommt das ist nämlich
out of the box was wo man sich denkt richtig dass jetzt ein ach das brauchen wir doch eigentlich
gar nicht und dann macht man es nicht die snapshot sie nur mit btfs ich bin mir nicht sicher vielleicht
auch mit ZFS, aber ich glaube
nicht mit ZFS, weil
Krupp und so haben keinen Support
für ZFS-Snapshots.
Also wahrscheinlich nur mit BTFS,
denke ich mal.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
bei den meisten Kisten spricht ja auch nichts
wirklich dagegen, BTFS zu verwenden.
Ist eigentlich
bei BTFS mittlerweile
Raid 5 und 6
stable oder gibt es immer noch eine Warnung?
Also lass mal kurz gucken.
WTFS Raid 6.
Ist es sicher zu verwenden?
Stand September 2005 wird von der Verwendung von WTFS mit Raid 5 noch abgerannt.
Ja, seit 20 Jahren oder so.
Youqueenforum.de
Ja, also
Die sagen selbst, man soll es nicht verwenden
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen
Dass das
Wahrscheinlich bei 99,99% der Leute
Keinerlei Probleme macht
der name cash us originate vom cash ist das ist der dachte ich mir auch das was damit zu tun
hast du hast du oft kack was kakule kakule kakule oder ist es oder es ist französisch heißt oder so
die kühle kann aber ich kann kein französisch hatte dich letzten stream wegen junior linux
vorstellungsgespräch gefragt habe mich mit set servers vorbereiten liefern exzellent
exzellent warst du das ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher oder meinte die zu dir gesagt haben du
Du sollst per SSH dich irgendwo einloggen und was zeigen?
Doch, oder?
Erzähl mal.
Was wollten die so wissen von dir?
Ist ja, denke ich, auch für den Chat ganz interessant.
Die sind ja vielleicht auch mal in der Lage,
das dann irgendwann oder in der Situation,
das machen zu müssen.
Erzähl uns doch mal,
was die was sie genau von dir vorgeführt haben wollten also wie gesagt es kann
ich empfehlen auch wie gesagt das ist nicht das allerbeste system für
einsteiger so nach dem motto werden alle noch gar nichts null blieb los
berufspunkte hat ist es geht das ja es ist vielleicht nicht das beste dafür
kann man aber ohne probleme machen ich finde es gut ich habe das jetzt seit ein
monaten hier schon mit kd auf so eine mini pc ist ein beeling sr 7 oder beelink sr 7
also ein teil und kleiner mini pc ist auch muss auch sagen es ist jetzt gar nicht so extrem
ramm hungrig ist jetzt ja hier das ding hat tatsächlich nur 8 g gramm ich habe bin auch
zu geizig gerade mehr zu kaufen 8 g gramm aber dafür hat es halt ordentlich wenn ich tippen
8 core Ryzen CPU ohne AMD Grafikkarte also eigentlich für Linux perfekt also ich könnte
es also ich würde es wieder installieren auf der Kiste
man spricht ja eigentlich auch gar nicht BTRFS aus wobei ich das persönlich die beste Aussprache
finde ich glaube es heißt entweder butter fs oder better fs aber ganz
ehrlich ich sage immer ein btr fs aber ext4 nicht xt
Okay, also erstmal haben sie dich Basics-Sachen gefragt.
Schau dich mal im System um, finde mal raus, was da so drauf ist.
Ja, okay.
Dann die Frage, wenn ich dir den Server für 50 Euro im Monat vermieten würde, wäre das fair?
wahrscheinlich können sie mit
Hetzenerpreis nicht mithalten.
Ja gut,
das sind ja durchaus
angemessene Fragen für
eine Einstiegsstelle,
wo man sieht, okay, die Leute haben ein bisschen
Ahnung von Linux, ja,
guckst du mal, was unter etc so
Zeug für Config-Dateien liegen, guckst du mal,
was für Packages installiert sind, guckst du mal überhaupt nach,
was das für ein System so ist,
ja, kannst du
etc.debian-version,
red hat version einmal linux version was auch immer die angucken oder lsb release was es dann
auch gibt gibt es ja zig zu zig so dateien ja aber das war schön ja und war das jetzt erste
bewerbungsrunde oder haben die schon gesagt die neben dich wie ist das dann am ende wie war das
dann? Business Komponenten. Was? Cack Business? Also ein bisschen Business hat ja mittlerweile
jede Stelle. Okay, außer vielleicht IBM Mainframe Admins oder sowas. Die gibt es wahrscheinlich
Das B-Tree-F-File-System.
Manchmal noch Butter-FS.
Sag ich doch.
Ja.
Warte, das gibt es erst seit 2016?
Das gibt es erst 10 Jahre?
Mir kommt das länger vor.
Achso, Moment. Seit 2007.
Okay.
Moment, plattformübergreifend?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Es gibt BTFS für Windows?
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Ja, was es nicht alles gibt, das wusste ich nicht, dass es BTFS für Windows gibt.
ein bisschen mit business also kommt drauf an was du meinst du bist also ein bisschen
mit bürstet das ja auch schon zu tun weil die leute wollen ja von dir irgendwelche features
haben aufgrund von weil irgendwelche anwender gesagt haben sie hätten das gerne weil irgendjemand
von euren Businessleuten meint, das ist sinnvoll.
Ja,
also ein bisschen
Überschneidung hat das immer.
Ich habe auch so gut wie nichts
mit Business zu tun, ja.
Das Einzige, was ich mit
Kick-Business zu tun habe, ist, wenn
mal wieder irgendeiner sagt, können wir die
4Ms nicht ein bisschen kleiner
seißen, dass sie nicht so teuer sind, oder
sowas.
Das gibt es auch für Windows.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass wir das schon hatten.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Aber mir ist es neu.
Tatsächlich.
Ja, KDE.
KDE gab es, glaube ich, auch mal für Windows.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile wird das nicht mehr unterstützt.
Was richtig cool war,
ist aber schon uralt.
Wie hieß das denn?
das war lange vor WSL
Co-Linux?
hieß das vielleicht so?
ja
das ist uralt, das ist von 2004
das ist uralt
also das ist nichts, was man jetzt irgendwie noch verwenden sollte
aber
das war quasi
WSL
bevor es WSL offiziell von Microsoft gab
die haben quasi den Linux-Kanal
auf Windows laufen lassen
Is a port of the Linux kernel.
Ja, da denke ich auch nie dran,
dass LinkedIn zu Microsoft gehört.
Das ist eigentlich richtig cool.
Du konntest damals Ubuntu,
boah, keine Ahnung, 8.10 oder irgendwie sowas,
oder Knobbix oder sonst was,
konntest du damals schon mit GUI, wohlgemerkt,
mit GUI,
konntest du unter Windows laufen lassen.
Guck hier, das ist ein Knobbix von damals.
dass der zug steht dürft ihr euch nicht beeindrucken lassen das ist nur für den
damals so für den x server gewesen also dass das war wie das war wsl bevor es wsl von microsoft gab
linux köln 26 ist halt schon bis sie eltern
das sind keine container ich habe das habe ich mich auch schon immer gefragt und ich
Ich habe keine Antwort drauf, wie man das genau macht.
Also sie haben den Linux-Körnel wohl irgendwie kompiliert für Windows.
Ich checke es auch nicht genau.
Weil wenn du zwei Körnel nebeneinander laufen hast, die kommen sich doch auch mit Speicherverwaltung und so voll in die Quere.
Sagt eine Anwendung, ey, ich hätte gerne RAM, dann macht das irgendwie Virtual Memory und im Zweifelsfall landest du dann auf dem Gleichen.
wahrscheinlich also meine vermutung ist ja dass sie den dass die den linux
kölner quasi als wie nennt man das user programm oder so laufen lassen oder als
oder als windows kölner im modul oder irgendwie sowas und die die die echten
hardware zugriffe irgendwie abstrahieren und umbiegen auf windows kölner sachen
Ich habe aber echt kein
Plastenschimmer, wie die das genau gemacht haben.
Keine Ahnung, das habe ich mich schon immer
gefragt, aber eigentlich richtig cool
damals gewesen. Ich habe das auch tatsächlich mal eine Weile
damals auf meinem Arbeitslaptop
2008 oder so verwendet.
Richtig coole Sache. Leider
wurde das nie wirklich
groß
angenommen.
und nie weiterentwickelt aber an sich war das das wie gesagt das war wsl wsl 1 wohl
gemerkt wsl 1 weil wsl 2 ist ja eigentlich auch nur eine vm unter der haube das quasi
wsl 1 lange lange 15 jahre bevor es wsl gab also das war ein richtig cooles projekt damals
Ja
Ja so spannend ist das nicht
Im Endeffekt sieht es halt aus wie WSL mit einem X-Server
Dann
Dann wird Miniri weiter
Ich weiß nicht, mir geht es halt nicht so gut
Deswegen habe ich den Stream angeschmissen, um mich ein bisschen abzulenken
deswegen ist der titel des streams tatsächlich auch nur zur hälfte kapper
weil ich weil zu mir hat man als ich als ich noch hier therapie gemacht habe vor
einem jahr hat man mein psychologe damals gesagt also der wo dem habe ich
immer irgendwann erzählt dass ich live stream mache und er hat gesagt weißt was
also, hat er nicht so gesagt, aber sinngemäß
hat er gesagt, weißt du was?
Ähm, wenn ihr dir mal so viele
Gedanken macht, dir es nicht so gut geht, mach doch einfach
Strieb an. Und da hab ich mir gedacht,
exzellente Idee.
Dann mach ich das doch.
LX
Core Sys ist der Kerneldriver des
WSL 1. Aha.
Okay, das scheint echt komplizierte Sache zu sein.
Okay, das...
Beim Umschauen im System habe ich Systemctl gesehen, ja.
Dass da ein Apache-Server drauf ist, der beim Starten fällt.
Das sollte ich mir angucken.
Dann habe ich die Logs geguckt, gesehen, woran es liegt und die Zeile geändert.
Okay, dann haben die das halt extra so manipuliert, um zu wissen, ob man so die Basics kann.
Übrigens was auch immer praktisch ist um zu gucken was drauf ist
System ctl system ctl list und da gibt es hier so ein paar sachen da macht man meistens list
List units oder list unit files list units da sieht man was es hier für start
skriptors quasi unit files drauf gibt
danach wurde gesagt dass ich das ganze system updaten soll man ab denn ist dns
resolving gefehlt gefällt weil er in resulten lokal ausstand als letztes sollte ich sehr
mord die exekute rechte wegnehmen und das fixen hat versuch kaltes zu deinstallieren
ging nicht aber install ging als gefixt aha war geil ja das ist richtig gut da siehst du die haben
sich tatsächlich mal was bei gedacht und wollen die dich jetzt haben oder oder weiß man noch nicht
hast du noch kontakte selten also zum kaboom schon ewig nicht nichts mehr zum zum fabian ab und zu
mal über discord aber auch selten gibt auch aktuell nichts was wir zusammen spielen können
Wisst ihr, was ich letztens gesehen habe?
Das
Bann
Also hier
Hack JavaScript
Das
Ähm, dass Bun
jetzt
rewritet zu Rust.
Habt ihr das auch gelesen?
Ne, mit beiden keinen Kontakt.
Ähm, was, also was der Danny macht,
hab ich keine Ahnung.
Schon ewig nix gehört.
so ja und bahn wurde jetzt irgendwie zu von sick zu rast oder soll von sick zu rast geportet werden
so genau check ich es ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum, ähm, zumindest, also meine persönliche Vermutung ist, ja,
dass, ach ist das jetzt schon hier die Rust-Geschichte, ja, BoringSSL, das klingt sehr nach Rust,
Also, meine Vermutung ist ja,
die porten das zu Rust,
damit sie sagen können,
guckt mal her, wie geil Cloud Code ist,
weil BUN gehört ja Anthropic.
Das sind die Cloud Code Leute.
Hinter BUN mittlerweile.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
das ist eigentlich in Haupten mal wieder so ein Prestigeprojekt
für Anthropic, dass sie sagen können,
Guckt mal, wir haben eine komplette JavaScript-Runtime.
Wobei, das stimmt ja gar nicht so wirklich.
Die JavaScript-Runtime ist ja die von Safari bei BAN, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
Alle anderen benutzen V8.
Das ist die JavaScript-Runtime von Chrome.
Oder von Chrome kann man ja gar nicht mal sagen.
Plink?
Wie heißt das jetzt genau?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Chrome, weiß jeder, was gemeint ist.
Die JavaScript-Runtime von Chrome.
oder die JavaScript Engine von Chrome oder wie man es nennen mag.
Und Bun benutzt die JavaScript Engine von Safari.
Ehrlich gesagt, absolut kein Schimmer, was sie dazu geritten hat,
irgendwas von Safari freiwillig zu verwenden.
Safari ist ja im Prinzip der neue Internet Explorer.
Also wenn es ein cooles neues Feature gibt und Chrome und Firefox können das Feature,
kannst du es erstmal die nächsten 5 Jahre nicht benutzen,
bis Safari es irgendwann mal auf die Reihe gekriegt hat.
safari ist teilweise richtig outdated overrated gebetet
und ich hab die ich habe mir das gefühl dass das ich habe keine ahnung warum sie es wirklich
porten ja jeder ios browser muss safari benutzen ja ja ich weiß aber trotzdem sagt safari es gibt
ja es gibt ja diese seite hier kennt i use so schau mal was okay guck mal was date wie
heißt diese neue date date new ds date time wie heißt dieser kram ja da gibt's auch eine neue
Temporal
Der Chat weiß wieder Bescheid
So, gucken wir mal
Haha, wer hätte gedacht
Jeder kann es, wer kann es nicht
Safari kann es nicht
Kein Wunder, Alter
Das ist immer der gleiche
Kack
Die können das
Oh, oh, oh
Im Safari
Technology Preview
Kann man jetzt eine Runtime-Flag setzen, Use Temporal, dann geht das auch.
Guck mal, wie lang Chrome und Firefox diesen Mist schon haben.
Das ist jetzt auch relativ neu, muss man dazu sagen.
Aber das ist immerhin schon über ein Jahr alt.
Spielst du Battlefield 6? Ne.
Ich habe letztens gesehen, es gibt wohl eine Map in Deutschland jetzt bei Battlefield 6.
Ja, wie auch immer die Safari-Updaten, aber die sind bekannt dafür, richtig weit hinten dran zu sein.
Bei vielen Features.
Wo die auch richtig lange gebraucht haben ist, weiß gar nicht, ob man das damit findet,
bei dem was du für eine progressive web application pva brauchst das hat ewig gebraucht
gebraucht ich weiß es ich weiß es leider nicht genau wie die ganzen vier guck mal hier das ist
auch für safari weil das haben die als gefahr für ihren app store gesehen und dann haben sie sich
gedacht nö da haben wir keinen bock dran ja also safari ist ich deswegen sage ich immer safari ist
der der neue internet explorer die sind teilweise jahre hinten dran bei dem was
die was sie für features haben das ist das ist teilweise echt kannst du kannst
du kannst ja eigentlich nahezu sicher sein wenn es irgendwas neues cooles gibt
wie zum beispiel die neue der time api und firefox und chrome unterstützen
endlich kann sagen okay eigentlich so richtig verwenden kann man es noch nicht
weil safari benutzt das halt oder safari hat immer noch nicht drin
Oh Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz, ich muss mal dringend kurz pinkeln.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Mach ich mal eine Runde.
Oh, ich hab Bauchweh.
WTF, was ist denn jetzt los?
Ich hab eine Riesenportion Spargel, grüne Spargel mit Kartoffel gegessen.
Also jetzt nix.
Oh, WTF, was ist denn jetzt los?
Also im Plan steht, dass ich gerade übelst Bauchweh hab.
So von jetzt auf gleich.
Okay, es kann durchaus sein, dass ich nicht nur pinkeln muss, sondern gleich mal afklo.
Ja, aber jetzt muss ich mal, Leute, ich muss mal kurz pinkeln.
Ich guck mal, vielleicht kann ich das andere auch gleich mit erledigen.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich hab doch hier sogar so ein afklo.
Okay, Leute, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, wieder am Start.
Also
Da bin ich wieder
Wie gesagt, die
Kann sein, dass ich gleich nochmal muss
Gucken wir, wie das mit dem Bauchweh
Bauchweh sich entwickelt
Wo sind wir denn gerade stehen geblieben? Achso, ich hab Safari geflamed
Dass Safari der neue Internet Explorer ist
Geht's besser? Ich war nur pinkeln
Guck, vielleicht legt sich das mit Bauchschmerzen
Ja, wieder. Genau, ich hab Safari geflamed
Dass Safari der neue Internet Explorer ist
Und wie sind wir da hingekommen? Genau, von
Bun, weil Bun
Ja, Safari, glaube, als
JavaScript Engine verwendet
Genau, und jetzt haben sie Bun
Irgendwie zu
Rust
Portiert
Wahrscheinlich ist da
Für Cloud Code
Drei Wochen gelaufen oder so
Kann man VMware Workstation auch ohne Account downloaden?
Also offiziell von VMware nicht, aber vielleicht findest du ja irgendwo bei Heise oder Chip
oder sonst wo den Download.
Aber du kannst ja auch einfach einen Account mit Fake-Email-Adresse machen, ne?
Hier ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10-Minute-Mail oder sowas.
Suchst dir irgendeine random Adresse raus und registrierst dich bei VMware.
Ja.
Zumindest wofür der
Bun Rust Port
schon geflamed wurde,
also das hier, das ist alles
Cloud Code Generated,
wofür das schon geflamed
wurde, ist,
dass die
so oft unsave
verwenden.
Was ist denn das?
Kann man sich trauen, das aufzumachen?
The best disposable mail service.
Aha.
Was es nicht alles gibt, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Wann wurde es schon öfters?
Guck mal hier.
Die haben so viel unsaved.
WTF Pass Double
Das hat halt einfach
Cloud Code hat
SIG zu Rust mit Unsafe drin geportet
Da wurde
Unsafe Rust, da wurde
BUN schon wieder heftig geflamed, auch bei Hacker News
und allem
Ich glaube Theo hat auch ein Video zu, wo er die
geflamed hat
Ich persönlich
verstehe
den Port von
Bann zu Rust
nicht.
Ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass es halt so ein Marketing
Ding von Anthropic wieder ist.
Wie gesagt, die Cloud Code Leute,
denen gehört ja Bann mittlerweile.
Was ich in der Tat ganz interessant finde, was ich
schon immer mal ausprobieren wollte, wo ich mir
gar nicht sicher bin,
ob wir das nicht sogar schon mal ausprobiert haben.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Ähm.
Was ich mal schon immer ausprobieren wollte ist,
BAN hat, das könnten wir theoretisch jetzt sogar mal schnell ausprobieren,
BAN hat ja die Möglichkeit, dass man Standalone Executables baut
aus JavaScript-Anwendungen.
BAN self-contained executable.
Kann man bauen.
und
ihr libc
da kann man target auswählen
so und was mich jetzt mal
interessieren würde ist
wenn ich
ähm
hier mit
mit ban linux x64
musel
das ganze kompiliere ob es dann
wirklich ein richtig
echtes stand alone
binary ist so ein bisschen wie go oder ob das nach wie vor abhängig ist zu
jeweiligen lebt sie implementierung und dementsprechend dann nur auf neueren
linux system läuft wenn man es auf neueren linux system computer das
probieren wir jetzt mal aus ich mein das dauert ja nicht lang
wir installieren einfach mal bahn boden so dann machen wir ein hello world
javascript
Gucken wir mal.
CD, Temp.
Ich habe noch keinen Temp.
MKD,
BAN, LEL.
WIM,
MAIN.JS,
CONSOLE.
Was? LOG ist es, ne?
CUTE CHAT.
Ah ja, ja.
So.
Beste. BAN.
Kann man jetzt die Datei einfach so ausführen?
Okay, Funst. So, wie geht das
jetzt denn nimmst du nicht die dev container dafür also für ein einzelnes javascript fall
was ich packe nicht normalerweise nämlich der container dafür der freundin ist übrigens immer
noch kaputt auf der echten hardware linux kiste keine ahnung warum aber für diese also für ein
für die einzel javascript datei die ich damit jetzt bahn will dann brauche ich das nicht aber
ansonsten nämlich immer der container was man übrigens auch gesehen hat dass das sehr sinnvoll
ist, weil
Ja, keiner nimmt
die erste Seite, die hier was gefunden hat.
Weil
Mini-Shyhulut
ist wieder am Start.
Supply Chain
Angriff affecting
CanStack.
Es gab
wieder NPM Supply Chain Angriffe.
Das ist aber ja mittlerweile eigentlich gar keine News mehr wert, weil das eh jede Woche mindestens einmal vorkommt.
Keck.js, ja.
To support CPUs from before 2000...
Okay.
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen...
Ah, Minus Baseline ist für alte CPUs.
Verstehe.
Okay, dann probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Wir kompilieren das mit BAN und dann gucken wir mal, wie sehr rückwärtskompatibel das Ganze ist.
Main.
Also wir kompilieren es für Linux x64.
So, also auf dem gleichen System sollte das ja funktionieren.
Okay, passt.
Wir können mal kurz gucken was das sagt ob das static oder beine ob das static das ist okay das ist dynamic link
Das wird schon mal probleme geben das auszupuff auszuführen auf ein bisschen älteren system probieren das noch mal aus docker run
einmal linux näher kommen wir nehmen wir irgendwas
debian
auf tricks tricks sie könnte es tatsächlich laufen debian tricks sie
Ach nee wir müssen das ja mountain minus v kann man mittlerweile so was eigentlich machen in docker
Nach app es geht nicht
Muss man machen
Max tmp
pwd ja ach das muss der form er sagen was hat er für schmerzen
was wo ist das was was für ein problem
jetzt so dumm doch zu starten gerade
will ich das muss auch vor dem jan trixie okay nichts gesagt dem jan trixie
Alter!
Sag mal...
Jetzt will ich ja...
So, Moment.
Donker, run!
Also so funkt es das ja prinzipiell.
Das muss doch so funktionieren.
Was hat er denn?
Invalid Spec. App.
Empty Section.
Empty Section?
Aber das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Hä?
Es ist doller PwD.
Aber.
Okay.
Jetzt.
Okay, das war echt eine schwere Geburt.
So, gehen wir mal hier nach
Slash App.
So, geht nicht.
Weil
Lip Ico ist nicht drauf.
Ach, das braucht der auch.
Okay.
Kann man das irgendwie static kompilieren?
Wann?
Nee.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt das nächste.
Probieren wir mal.
Also das funktioniert schon nochmal nett.
Wie man sieht, das ist...
Dann muss man das wieder auf dem richtig alten Linux kompilieren, wenn man will, dass das funktioniert.
Sie haben sogar LibEco als Anforderung.
Also so wirklich schön self-contained ist die Anwendung ja nett, muss man sagen.
So, dann sagen wir ban.
Äh, Moment hier.
Ban.
Ban compile.
ne, BUN, BILD, COMPILE, TARGET
was war das andere?
BASELINE
äh, BASE, wenn man das noch nicht schreiben will
ok, ist
von 97
FILE, MY APP
ist immer noch dynamically linked
aber, guck mal, tatsächlich
für ein älteres Linux jetzt auch
APP
Das funktioniert schon immer
Das ist gut zu wissen
Also wenn man Linux x64
Baseline nimmt
Dann ist das schon mal
Auch laufweg auf älteren
Linux System, Debian ist ja standardmäßig älter
Wir machen jetzt nochmal
Ein richtig altes Linux
Was ist richtig 12
Ne, 13.
Trixie ist 13.
Genau. Dann mal
Bookworm war davor. Dann machen wir jetzt mal
Debian 10.
Das war Weezy
oder irgendwie sowas.
Und das ist noch
älter. Geht immer noch.
Sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut.
Na gut, Kernel.
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Also, diese Kombination hier mit Baseline führt echt dazu, dass die Dinger ziemlich gut abwärtskompatibel sind.
Okay, machen wir mal was ganz Altes.
Debian Version.
Warte mal, lass mal gucken.
Wir nehmen jetzt mal einen Debian.
Jesse.
Jesse nehmen wir mal.
Das ist richtig alt.
Oder alternativ können wir auch Edge nehmen.
Edge war in meiner Ausbildung
voll angesagt noch.
Wir nehmen mal Jesse.
Übrigens, wer sich fragt, wo die Namen herkommen,
das sind alles Charaktere aus
Toy Story. Jesse ist
der Cowboy.
Dixie
ist der Dinosaurier.
Buster ist, glaube ich, der Hund.
Gut, Woody ist der Cowboy
Äh, Jessie ist die Cowboyin
Woody ist der Cowboy
Sarge ist glaube ich der
Der Spielzeugsoldat
Ja
Z ist das böse Kind, genau, ja
Guck mal
Die Anwendungen laufen rückwirkend
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, ich laufe ja immer noch, immer noch mit dem aktuellen Körner, ne?
Also ob das wirklich so lange rück... müsste man halt in der VM oder so mal testen.
Aber es sieht zumindest danach aus, als ist, wenn man BAN mit Baseline kompiliert, das eigentlich schon mal ganz gut, muss man sagen.
So, wie kann man das Ganze jetzt mit...
jetzt haben wir die jetzt haben wir keine gelb c sondern die musel variante ist die
static dieser die ich in diesen dies nicht fertig die ist auch dynamisch dagegen gelingt das ist
dann was für alpine linux und sowas weil das sollte jetzt immer funktionieren genau die
fehlermeldung ist ein bisschen dumm ja also die app ist schon da die fehler die
fehlermeldung ist ein bisschen bisschen bescheuert das geht nicht das geht nicht
weil das kein musel installiert hat sondern nur geliebt c das dann probieren
wir doch mal was anderes das finde ich immer ein bisschen also ganz ehrlich
es wäre viel besser wenn ihr die möglichkeit anbieten dass man wenn man
schon gegen musel linkt das statisch linken könnte weil aus der alpine benutzt keine linus
distribution musel musel ist eine mini c library implementierung die angeblich viel nicht portabler
ist oder so gibt es denn die möglichkeit wann ist das ding kompiliert an kompakt
static wird das vielleicht auch im klamm einstatt linken
ok das gibt es anscheinend nicht
Was?
I've looked deeper and Bun uses its own binary as a base to generate the compiled binary file.
Science Bun is not fully compiled static.
Moment, ich soll jetzt, damit ich ein statisches Binary erzeugen kann, soll ich Bun selbst erst statisch kompilieren oder was?
Ja, man könnte es ja auch übertreiben.
I decided to recompile Bun in a static way.
Wir müssen es ja mal nicht übertreiben, oder?
Okay.
Dann ist das schon ganz gut,
wie Ban das macht.
Aber es ist
nicht auf dem gleichen Niveau wie beispielsweise Go von der Portability her.
Portabilität oder wie soll man sagen?
Weil in Go-Binary, also ohne C-Go, ist komplett statisch.
Das kannst du auf Linux-Sidekernel 2632 draufschieben und es läuft.
Egal ob GLibc, Musel oder Ulibc oder was es da nicht alles gibt, vollkommen egal, es geht.
Und deswegen ist Go für portable Binaries einfach das Beste, was es gibt.
Deswegen ist das meiner Meinung nach auch so beliebt für CLI-Tools.
Weil ein CLI-Tool mit Go, also jetzt wie gesagt, ohne dass du externe Abhängigkeiten zu irgendwelchen C-Geschichten hast oder so,
ist super easy zu deployen oder auch zu containerisieren.
Das muss einfach reinkopiert werden, das läuft.
Du kannst bei Go sogar das Docker Scratch Image verwenden, wo nichts drin ist, quasi außer das Binary.
Das geht.
Also Go ist da schon wirklich sehr Premium.
So, wir probieren jetzt nochmal was aus.
Ich habe jetzt hier die GLibc Variante und wenn ich die jetzt mal starte in einem Alpine Linux,
Alpine Latest, dann sollte das ja eigentlich nicht funktionieren.
Achso, bin SH.
Ja.
App.
My App.
Bam.
Geht nicht.
Okay.
Aber das ist trotzdem ganz gut.
Also.
Also wenn ich jetzt eine Anwendung in JavaScript machen müsste.
Sagen wir auch irgendein CLI Tool.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen müsste ich das in JavaScript machen.
Weil spezielle Libraries nur für JavaScript gibt.
Und es damit so viel einfacher ist, dass sich das drumherum lohnt.
das dann nicht in Go zu machen oder in einer anderen Sprache
JavaScript,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
wirklich Ban benutzen,
um da meinen Binary draus zu
erzeugen. Also wenn ich
was suche, was ich verteilen will,
weil das ist, zumindest hier mit Baseline,
ist das nahezu auf allen
Linux-Distributionen der letzten, was weiß ich,
15 Jahre oder so lauffähig.
Oder der letzten 10 Jahre mindestens lauffähig.
Jesse ist von 2015 gewesen.
lauffähig die gelb c base sind was alle sind oder sagen wir zu 99 prozent die
lehrungsdiskussion sind die einzigen größere die mir einfällt die nicht gelb
c base ist die ist das ist alpine und alpine hat auch noch ein paar andere
probleme ich bin überhaupt keine alpine linux fan
mehr ich habe das früher gerne benutzt für container mittlerweile benutzt
entweder einfach stinknormales minimales debian weil die bisschen
bisschen größere image größe jetzt eigentlich gar keinen großen unterschied
macht das ist nicht das was teuer ist oder aber wenn es eine go anwendung ist
oder irgendwas was ich statisch kompilieren lässt dann entweder
distroless images oder scratch image
rust ich glaube ich glaube mein bann ist noch die sick variante oder ich war
stark von aus.
Warte mal. Release.
Ja, guck mal. Meins ist noch
die Sick-Variante.
Alpine hat immer mal wieder Probleme
mit DNS-Auflösung und sowas.
Wegen Lip-Musel.
Ja.
Ja, ist mega. Rust allerdings
zum Laufen zu bringen, braucht haufenweise
C-Abhängigkeit. Du kannst doch
mittlerweile Rust
static
als Rust
static binary kompilieren.
Das war doch gar nicht so kompliziert.
Du konntest doch, das haben wir doch sogar
mal im Stream gemacht, das war doch an sich
gar nicht so schwierig.
Du musstest im Endeffekt nur sagen, du willst
static Musel target
und dann ging das.
Gut, je nachdem, was für Abhängigkeiten
du natürlich hast, dann
wird es vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber an sich
war Rust relativ einfach, komplett
statisch zu kompilieren.
Du benutzt einmal Linux minimal.
Ey, einmal Linux, ich
wusste, dass es das gibt, ja.
Genauso wie Rockli Linux, so quasi als
kostenlose
Red Hat Varianten.
Aber die haben echt
Pluspunkte gesammelt letzte Woche bei mir.
So im Kopf, ne.
Weil, es erinnert euch ja bestimmt noch an
Dirty Frag.
So.
und da hat Alma Linux
vor Red Hat, lange vor Red Hat
nee, nee, ich mein Dirty
Frag, Copy Fail war vor zwei
Wochen, letzte Woche war Dirty Frag
mittlerweile ist es ja so
dass es jede Woche irgendwas gibt
Alter
ähm
und
Alma Linux hatte schon am
7. Mai
ein Testing Patch
für Dirty
fragt red hat hatte bis gestern mittag nur packages für red hat zehn glaube ich
lass doch mal gucken gucken wir mal was mittlerweile hat
das meine ich nicht moment
Ja.
Important, ja.
Mach Witz, Redhead.
Also du kannst
Rust gegen
Musel kompilieren und dann ist das
komplett statisch und
du brauchst dann eigentlich keine Abhängigkeiten.
Wo du Abhängigkeiten brauchst, ist
wenn deine
Rust-Dependencies selber
irgendwelche dependencies haben dann gibt es probleme ja zum beispiel gab es
längere zeit mal probleme mit open ssl zum beispiel aber ich kann dir das
zeigen das ist eigentlich relativ da muss ich aber meine alte vm neu starten
weil ich glaube ich habe hier kein rust kein rust drauf und ich weiß kann aus
dem kopf auch gar nicht mehr wie man es richtig einrichtet so das lassen wir
mal hier kurz was gucken red hat sagt genau fix okay mittlerweile
Guckt mal hier.
Chatge, guckt mal hier.
Übrigens, dann habe ich Mist erzählt.
Ich dachte, bis gestern Mittag gab es noch nichts.
Ach doch, doch, doch, okay.
Elften.
Elften, dann habe ich gestern Morgen geguckt.
Elften kam das raus und gestern kam dann acht und neun.
Wo ist Redhead neun?
Redhead neun?
Äh, hallo?
Achso, da unten geht die Seite noch weiter.
Red Hat 9.
Okay, also da muss ich sagen, guckt mal hier.
Da hat Alma Linux bei mir echt Pluspunkte gesammelt.
Alma Linux ist ja quasi ein, ich weiß gar nicht, was die offiziell zu sich sagen.
Das ist quasi ein Red Hat Nachbau, halt nur, genau.
Alma Linux OS, binary compatible with Red Hat Enterprise.
Das ist quasi ein Red Hat ohne Red Hat.
Die haben da Red Hat Logos und so Zeug ausgetauscht.
Also die nehmen quasi Red Hat Sources und bauen ein eigenes Betriebssystem draus.
Du hast quasi dann ein kostenloses Red Hat.
Und man muss mal gucken, bei Red Hat bezahlst du ordentlich Asche für.
Und Alma Linux hatte am 7.
Guck mal hier, am 7. hatten die schon Testing-Patches und später dann auch...
Guck mal, am 8.5.
Mittags am 8.5.
hatten die
Kernel-Patches draußen für Dirty
Frag. Und Red Hat
hatte das irgendwann gestern.
Also die waren vier Tage.
Die waren quasi als kostenloses
Red Hat vier Tage
schneller als bezahltes
Red Hat für ihre Patches.
Das ist schon nice, oder?
Mit Rocky Linux habe ich, ehrlich gesagt,
müssen wir mal gucken.
Haben die überhaupt sowas?
Haben die irgendwie sowas, wo man
da nachgucken kann?
Okay, da bin ich zu dumm, das für Rocky Linux zu finden.
Aber das ist schon nice.
Errata Rocky Linux.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Dirty.
Das ist es nicht.
Okay, dann weiß ich nicht, wie ich das hier finden soll.
Was bei mir dazu geführt hätte, wenn ich jetzt mich entscheiden müsste,
ich will ein freies, kostenloses Wordhead haben,
nämlich Rocky Linux oder Alma Linux,
hätte ich jetzt gesagt, die haben bei mir Pluspunkte gesammelt,
dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich erst mal mit Alma Linux rausbringen.
Aber wahrscheinlich waren die bei Rocky Linux ähnlich schnell.
Ich bin dazu dumm, das zu finden.
Ja.
Also finde ich sehr nice, dass die vier Tage schneller waren als Red Hat.
Das musst du erstmal hinkriegen, oder?
Ich meine, Red Hat kriegt massig Geld für.
Red Hat ist fett im Business Enterprise Umfeld vertreten, brauchen aber trotzdem vier Tage länger als ein kostenloser Red Hat Nachbau.
Da muss man doch echt mal Hut ab sagen vor Alma Linux.
So, dann machen wir jetzt mal was.
Ich gehe mal auf den dritten Test.
Ich starte mal kurz meine VM.
Da kann ich dir das nämlich zeigen.
Next Tag.
Ich hoffe, ich finde jetzt noch.
Weil die VM hatte ich jetzt schon ewig nicht mehr an.
Da hatte ich nämlich ein Rust-Projekt drauf.
Hoffentlich finde ich das.
Wo man das sieht.
Wie schön man das statisch
compilen kann mittlerweile.
So.
Repos.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Ne, hab ich auch nicht so verstanden,
dass du was dagegen hast.
Ich wollte dir das bloß mal zeigen,
wie es jetzt geht.
Das da?
Ist es das?
Run SH?
Albo?
Build SH?
Ja, genau.
Das musst du angeben.
Minus, minus, Target,
x86, x64, Anno, Linux,
Moose. Und es gibt
mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, dass du
nicht mehr OpenSSL verwenden musst,
sondern es gibt jetzt, ich glaube,
jetzt habe ich zu viele, oh man,
Chat, Leute, warte mal, ich habe zu viele
Sachen gerade offen, zu viele
Desktops mit Zeug drauf.
Es gibt jetzt Boring
SSL
Rust,
das ist quasi
ein Rust Open
SSL Port und die
meisten Packages,
also die meisten Rust
Dependents, also die meisten
Rust Crates, heißt
wenn man korrekt ist. Also die meisten Rust-Libraries unterstützen mittlerweile Boring-SSL anstelle von Open-SSL
und dementsprechend kannst du es auch statisch compilen.
Genau, so ging das. Ja, Bild, also einfach nur, man muss es glaube ich eigentlich, muss man einfach nur das hier sagen.
Minus, minus Target, vorher muss man das natürlich noch installieren, sonst meckert er rum.
Ist in dem Dockerfall noch irgendwas Spannendes drin gewesen?
Nee.
Ach nee!
Kanisterköppel, du warst das.
Nicht NextTag.
Dann hab ich euch gerade durch...
Weil ihr habt bei mir fast die gleiche Farbe im Chat.
Das hab ich durcheinander gebracht.
ok gut da mache ich die kiste mal wieder aus weil drei desktops mit drei unterschiedlichen
betriebssystemen drauf da hört es bei mir dann auch irgendwann mal im kopf auf wie ich da durchblicke
rocky linux still effected
Ach, das ist was Neues, oder?
Ja, ich finde so irgendwie
einen ordentlich durchsuchbaren Tracker ist echt
schon wichtig, dass man das auf
eine halbe Stunde suchen muss.
Jo.
Also einmal Linux, muss ich echt sagen,
fand ich echt nice.
Also ich habe es noch nie benutzt.
Also ich habe weder auf irgendeinem Server noch bei mir hier privat irgendwie oder bei Hetzner oder sonst wie jenen Alma Linux entsteht.
Aber wenn ich mal wirklich was Red Hat kompatibles brauchen sollte, würde ich wahrscheinlich Alma Linux nehmen.
Mal kurz gucken.
Seit wann es das gibt eigentlich?
Also wir können jetzt ja mal hier sagen.
ähm, in Bash.
Heißt das dann
einmal Linux?
Und dann?
Das kann man was schüren.
Ich weiß nämlich gar nicht, wie lang es das gibt.
Also ich weiß, das gibt es erst
seit CentOS nicht mehr CentOS.
Ähm, genau. Seit CentOS
nicht mehr CentOS ist.
Aber, wann war denn das?
Vor fünf Jahren oder so?
Gibt es da irgendwie eine Übersicht?
Versions oder sowas?
Also, was haben die?
Alma Linux 8, 9 und 10, oder?
Für was braucht man ein Red Hat kompatibles Linux?
Naja.
Also, ich kann dir einen Anwendungsfall sagen,
den ich aus der Praxis kenne.
wenn du nicht möchtest
lasst mich erst mal kurz diese eine sache fertig kommt also die haben
einen alman linux okay die haben 89 und 10 alles klar okay also die frage ist
wofür braucht man also ich kann dir ein beispiel nennen aus der praxis wo wir das
früher benutzt haben. Das war zwar noch CentOS,
aber ist ja egal. Letztendlich Red Hat
kompatibel ist. Oder sagen wir mal,
Red Hat ohne Red Hat.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du keinen
Bock hast,
für jedes deiner
Systeme Lizenzgebühren
zu bezahlen bei Red Hat,
aber du eine einheitliche
Umgebung haben möchtest.
So.
Und man könnte so weit gehen,
da sage ich natürlich nicht, dass wir das gemacht haben oder so,
könntest du auch so weit gehen und sagen, du kaufst dir drei, vier Systeme,
du kaufst dir quasi von jeder Hardware-Ausstattung ein System mit Red Hat Lizenz,
alle anderen Systeme lässt du mit Alma Linux laufen
und wenn du dann Support von Red Hat brauchst,
dann haben halt zufälligerweise immer die Systeme,
die du offiziell lizenziert hast, Probleme.
und nicht die einmal linux systeme
das sind dann zwar ganz schön fehleranfällige server aussicht von red hat aber das gehört
es zu machen und selbst wenn du das nicht machst wenn du einfach nur eine einheitliche umgebung
haben willst wenn du sagst ich brauche red hat zum beispiel für irgendwelche business enterprise
software also gehen wir mal von aus du du betreibst die was ich 50 kisten so
dass er sich so viel ist auch überschaubar
puff schädigungskisten aber das ist schon so ist es zu viel dass ich da dass
ich alles da immer von hand machen würde so und du sagst okay ich mache mir jetzt
einfach so 23 ansible playbooks um die sachen zu installieren die man also
braucht aber du hast halt kein bock deine ansible playbooks anzupassen dass
sie auf dem jan funktionieren dass sie auf rettet funktioniert dass sie auch
überall wirklich das gleiche machen aber du brauchst sagen wir mal für oracle
datenbanken oder irgendwelches andere business enterprise zeug brauchst du
halt ein paar offizielle red hat kisten die auch lizenziert sind
stellst du hin aber deine anderen linux systeme letztes halt gerne einheitlich
und da sagst okay wir entscheiden uns dafür machen dass red hat kompatibel und
Was PG bedeutet meistens?
Post-Crest, oder?
Ne.
Also, QA kann ich mir was darunter vorstellen.
Das ist quasi Testumgebung.
Oder Integrationsumgebung, wie das
automatisch heißt. Ach, Playground
heißt was bei euch.
Okay.
Finde ich witzig. Ich habe da schon die
unterschiedlichsten Namen für gehört.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit
ist es ein bisschen cursed.
Nicht so cursed wie auf der alten Arbeit,
muss ich dazu sagen.
Das kann ich vielleicht auch nochmal gleich erzählen.
Muss ich mal aufschreiben.
So.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit ist es ein bisschen cursed,
was die Umgebungsbezeichnung angeht.
Also, prinzipiell
haben wir
so die klassische Sache aus
Entwicklung,
Test,
integration produktion manche umgebung also sie sind nicht unbedingt pflicht ja das gibt es die
sind so die vier stages die da auch in einem job dauer und so auswählen kannst aber du brauchst
das nicht unbedingt also wenn du sagst ich habe ich brauche keine def umgebung weil dann nichts
gedacht wird dann kannst du dir auch weglassen ja das ist doch schon okay also diese vier stages
Es gibt es erstmal, ja.
Entwicklung, Tests, Integration und Produktion.
Und jetzt ist das Problem, weshalb das...
Arbeitst du bei einer Bank?
Nee, ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Aber ich habe davor bei einer Bank gearbeitet.
So, und was ein bisschen cursed ist,
die waren so schlau
und haben die Entwicklungsumgebung
lokal
Entwicklung genannt.
Also es gibt nicht eine Entwicklungsumgebung.
Ja, ich meine so die Stage-Entwicklung.
Heißt lokal Entwicklung,
nur dass sie es in der Cloud
in den Projekten Dev genannt haben.
So, und jeder, der jetzt
irgendwelche automatischen Auswertungen macht
oder irgendwas automatisiert, muss
immer ein If einbauen.
Ist es Dev oder ist es Entwicklung?
Das ist echt cursed.
das riecht das riecht nervig aber das ist nix gegen das wie es beim alten arbeitgeber war bei
meinem alten arbeitgeber war das war die umgebungsbezeichnung ultra also wirklich
ultra cursed und zwar da war es prinzipiell auch so es gab eine entwicklung es gab also
es gab einen test es gab eine integration es gab eine produktionsumgebung aber das war historisch
gewachsen die haben angefangen damals mit einem produkt mit mehr hatten die
mich ja die haben quasi ein produkt gehabt angeboten und dieses produkt gab
es ursprünglich nur als produktionsumgebung also die hatten
quasi Produkt A,
Produktion. Sonst hatten die nix.
Also das war zu den Zeiten,
als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet hab,
für die Bank damals.
So.
Das gab nur Produktionsumgebung.
Okay.
Irgendwann kam dann einer auf die
Idee und hat gesagt,
Leute,
Produktionsumgebung
alleine ist vielleicht
auch nicht so schlau. Wir sollten das
ganze noch mal aufbauen dass wir die sachen testen können bevor das dann immer kaputt geht also gab
es dann eine test umgebung und eine produktions umgebung so weit so gut dann kamen sie auf die
idee wir müssen ja unsere mitarbeiter mit der software schulen können deswegen bauen wir neben
der Produktionsumgebung noch eine Schulungsumgebung.
Und jetzt hat man den großen Fehler gemacht
und hat die Schulungsumgebung nicht als zweites Produkt eingeführt,
sondern als weitere Stage der eigentlichen Anwendung,
was überhaupt keinen Sinn macht.
Man hätte sagen müssen, wir haben zwei Produkte oder zwei Services.
Wir haben einmal unseren, was weiß ich, ich nenne es jetzt mal irgendwie was, unseren Dokumentenservice und unseren Dokumentenservice Schulung.
So, die zwei Sachen hätte man sagen müssen.
Nein, was hat man gemacht?
Man hat es quasi als weiteres Stage des Dokumentenservice hingestellt.
So, und jetzt habe ich mal eine Frage an euch.
Man hatte dann quasi die Umgebung, Test, Produktion, Schulung.
Wie würdet ihr jetzt eine Umgebung nennen, die die Schulungssoftware zu Testzwecken anbietet?
Da sind sie schnell auf die Idee gekommen
Wir nennen das ganze Ding Testschulung
Und jetzt hattest du das Problem
Du hattest eine Test
Du hattest eine Testschulung
Und in Produktion
Hattest du eine Produktion und eine
Schulung
Das heißt du hattest immer das Stage drinnen
außer bei Schulung
und das andere, das war schon echt
cursed und dann haben sie es komplett
kaputt gemacht, dann haben sie es komplett kaputt gemacht
dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wir brauchen das
zur besseren Unterscheidbarkeit
müssen wir immer noch
das Produkt da irgendwie
dran schreiben, so
und dann, und dann
ohne Scheiß, ja
dann kamen dann solche Dinger bei raus
ähm
zumindest, sie haben dann gesagt
okay, wir behalten das bei
Das heißt dann quasi Dokumentensystemproduktion, Dokumentensystemschulung. Das Dokumentensystemschulung war quasi die produktive Schulungsumgebung des Dokumentensystems. Aber noch viel besser ist, wie hätten wir jetzt die Testumgebung nennen sollen?
Und dann hießen diese Umgebung
Allen Ernstes, Leute, ich
Wie hat der Asitoni gesagt? Ich lüsch net
Alles, alles
Das war so
Dann hatten wir eine Testumgebung, die hieß
Testproduktion
Und Testschulung
Das ist richtig cursed, oder?
Testproduktion, Alter
Das ist so hängen geblieben, man
Die Testproduktion, Alter.
Und da gab es dann wirklich Leute, die haben dann gesagt, ja, in Testbrot.
Und Leute, die neu da waren, die haben gesagt, was ist denn eine Testbrot?
Warum braucht man überein eine Testumgebung für die Schulung?
Na, weil das zwar im Kern die gleiche Software ist, aber mit komplett anderer Config und irgendwelchen Hilfetexten in der Software und hast du nicht gesehen.
Die hat das unterscheidet, das unterschied sich schon.
Also im Prinzip hätte man von Anfang an sagen müssen, es gibt zwei verschiedene Sachen, die wir anbieten.
Wir bieten einmal Dokumentensystem an und Dokumentensystem-Schulungssoftware.
So hätte man es von Anfang an machen müssen.
Wie oft wurden da Dinge auf Produktion gespielt, die eigentlich auf Test sollen?
Fällt mir jetzt gar nicht ein, dass das überhaupt passiert ist.
Wir haben uns da immer nur betrubelustig gemacht, aber gewusst hat es trotzdem jeder.
Oh, ich habe gerade was getrunken.
Exzellenter Hinweis, Chat.
Pfeifhead.
Ach ja.
Da gibt es schon immer abgedrehte Sachen.
gibt es eigentlich ein abt zu pw safe auf der arbeit ja ja alles alles umgestellt ich habe
meine saves mit meiner software konvertiert wie die anderen das gemacht haben keine ahnung
repot finde ich auch eklig ganz ehrlich ich mag das wie wir es aktuell auf der arbeit
haben entwicklung test integration produktion was finde ich eigentlich nicht schlecht
er sagt hier einfach hier error free programming
efe error free programmen wenn du keine fehler machst ja wenn du wenn immer alles
fast drei funktioniert du sparst dir ganz viel testsysteme dokumentation kommentare alles
einfach nie fehler machen
So, Chat, ich muss nochmal kurz pinkeln.
Ich glaube, ich habe zu viel getrunken vorhin.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Wieder da.
Leute, ich muss euch mal sagen, ich liebe meinen Klo.
Das ist einfach die beste Investition gewesen.
Neben meinem...
Hier, Bürostuhl.
Einfach beste, Leute.
Ja, der da.
Warum kriegt...
Warum wird neben...
Warum habe ich hier das Icon vom Lost?
Das macht doch gar keinen Sinn.
Okay, whatever.
Ja.
Beste.
Der Klo hier.
Mit...
Guck.
Mit Spülung.
Ja, mit Spülung.
Guck, da kommt jetzt
der...
die Düse rausgefahren,
wenn man da drauf drückt.
Guck hier, Düse.
Und dann, bam!
In the Bobbis.
Oder nicht in, an den Bobbis.
Das ist so angenehm.
Beste.
Also, das ist nicht ganz so krasses
Japan-Klo, da hat beispielsweise
keine geheizte
Brille und sowas.
Aber da kann das Wasser
warm machen.
Das Wasser kann der, ja, ja, das kann der.
Das kann der.
So, habe ich jetzt irgendwas übersehen? Ich habe mich jetzt lange
drüber lustig gemacht, über irgendwelche
Umgebungsbezeichnungen.
gibt es nicht diese ängste alternative opel tofu heißt die opel tofu ist
genauso wie Nexta schon geschrieben hat,
ist ein Terraform-Fork
und
ich glaube,
Open Tofu
ist damals entstanden, weil
HashiCorp, das sind die Leute, die
Terraform programmieren,
weil die irgendwas
an ihren Lizenzbedingungen
geändert haben.
Ja, Simonos Handy
habe ich eigentlich immer dabei.
Das war doch das.
Die haben aber irgendwas in ihren Lizenzbedingungen geändert
und dann haben die Open Tofu gefolgt.
Und mittlerweile ist Open Tofu sehr beliebt.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit wird auch mittlerweile Open Tofu verwendet.
Anstatt Terraform.
Terraform ist outgefaced.
Aber ich meine, im Prinzip funktioniert der Terraform-Code
quasi genauso in Open Tofu auch.
Und dazu muss man noch sagen, dass Terraform bzw. Open Tofu eigentlich nicht wirklich eine Alternative zu Ansible ist. Also kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen drüber streiten. Ansible und Terraform haben schon eine gewisse Überschneidung.
Ja, und du kannst mit Ansible auch viel von dem machen, wofür du Terraform verwendest. Du kannst mit Terraform auch einiges machen, was du mit Ansible machst. Aber grundsätzlich muss man sagen, dass beides unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte hat.
Terraform wird meistens dafür verwendet, um Infrastruktur aufzubauen,
also zum Beispiel VMs zu professionieren bei einem Cloud-Anbieter
oder um Kubernetes-Cluster-Datenbanken aufzubauen.
Und Ansible wird benutzt, um die VMs danach so einzurichten, wie sie eben sein müssen.
Also, wenn man komplexere Konfigurationen hat,
dann ist die kombination aus beidem durchaus sinnvoll ja dann sagst du okay
ich habe jetzt hier mal ein terraform file ich baue damit 20 vms auf und
danach lässt du auf allen diesen vms kann sich auch einen automatischen job
machen beim ersten startup oder über cloud in it oder sonst was lässt du den
ersten lässt du einen job laufen der dann die vms einrichtet ja der dann zum
guck sind alle user da sind alle tools installiert sind alle zertifikate
trusted ach was auch immer was du halt auf deinen ganzen linux servern haben willst das ist deutlich
einfacher und angenehmer mit ernte bild zu machen als in terraform weil terraform hat da eigentlich
nichts für bei terraform müsstest du da halt irgendwelche skripte letztendlich laufen lassen
wobei ist wahrscheinlich auch einige terraform provider gibt dafür aber in der regel kannst du
sagen terraform ist für den aufbau der infrastruktur ende bild ist für das kommt also
zum aufbauen von vms in dem fall und ansible ist für das konfigurieren von vms also infrastruktur
terraform config ansible wo es natürlich trotzdem halt bei beiden überschneidungen gibt ja du kannst
es gibt beispielsweise für ansible auch einen google cloud provider wie heißt das bei ansible
Modul? Bei Ansible heißt es glaube ich Modul. Da kannst du damit auch VMs aufbauen, aber Terraform ist da schon mehr für gemacht als Ansible.
Deswegen am besten ist, wenn man da komplexere Anwendungsfälle hat, man verwendet einfach beides.
Und mit Terraform baut man seine Infrastruktur auf und mit Ansible konfiguriert man dann die aufgebauten VMs.
Dankeschön für den Sub, McFly.
Pog Subscription.
Exquisite.
Subscriber.
So.
Chat, ich muss mal gerade
meine Hose ordentlich richten.
So.
Gut.
Dann hätten wir das.
Chat, ich habe nichts geplant für den Stream heute.
Großartig, ne?
Ist Open Tofu auch für
Container Management gut?
Du kannst damit...
Also nee, ist es nicht. Um es mal kurz zu machen.
Oder was meinst du mit Containermanagement?
Sowas anzulegen wie einen Cloud Run oder auf irgendeiner Managed Container Form irgendeine Function ausführen oder sowas.
So Dinge anlegen kannst du gut mit Terraform machen.
aber wofür terraform nicht gut ist ist für konfiguration von dem kubernetes
cluster oder konfiguration von vms also zum beispiel was du wunderbar machen
kannst mit terraform ist zu sagen ja das kannst du gut mit terraform machen also
die cloud run heißt das bei google zum beispiel google cloud run das kannst du
wunderbar mit terraform machen
Ist das das Richtige?
Ja.
Genau.
Guck.
So sieht das dann in...
Hä?
Warum sieht das so kacke aus?
Ah, hier.
Das suche ich.
Ah, ja.
Das sieht auch schon eklig aus.
Aber das kannst du in Terraform machen.
kannst sagen hier guckt cloud run container so dass das dafür ist dafür ist terraform gut für
solche sachen ja aber erst mal zurückzugehen was ich eigentlich sagen wollte also terraform ist
auch wunderbar um zu sagen ich hätte gerne einen kuba nettes cluster und zwar mit diesen und diesen
not types und die dinger sollen die not sollen so viel ram haben und ich will maximal vier notes
haben diese ip-adress ranges für den cluster und sowas dafür ist terraform wunderbar wofür
terraform nicht so geil es ist wenn der cluster dann steht zu sagen ja ich brauche dann noch
einen manager drin das manager soll folgende konflikt bekommen und dann brauchen wir noch
hier eine message also so konflikt von dem cluster dann innen drin also quasi den cluster benutzen
das geht ja es gibt den cube ctl plugin für terraform und auch ein paar andere
dinge man kann das machen also man kann ja quasi cube kubernetes
jammel in terraform irgendwie schreiben war ganz ehrlich nur weil das geht heißt
es noch lange nicht dass es eine gute idee ist
da würde ich lieber was anderes verwenden
dann würde ich mir dann ein git repo machen wo meine ganzen kubernetes sachen
als jammelfeil drin liegen und wenn man es automatisieren will kann man es ja
immer noch mit flux oder agro cd machen also auf jeden fall die bessere variante
als seine kubernetes quasi inhalt vom cluster noch irgendwie in terraform rein
pressen
der provider gibt es aber ich finde es trotzdem nicht nicht sinnig
du meinst du meinst diese geschichte dass ihr genau dass die telekom extra
geld extra geld von cloud hat sie gab es da nicht letztens sogar ein urteil zu
habe ich da nicht irgendwas in den news gelesen
aber war das mal kurz gucken telekom urteil ich habe doch letztens
irgendwas gelesen
Okay, oder auch nicht.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Details kann...
Also, ich kann es dir...
Also, ich kann es dir technisch erklären, ja.
Aber ich kann dir nicht die...
die genauen Hintergründe erklären.
Dafür habe ich mich nicht genau damit...
genug damit beschäftigt,
warum die Telekom das macht.
und was damit Cloudflare läuft.
Weil so, die wollen irgendwie extra Geld für den Traffic von Cloudflare haben
und Cloudflare sagt, habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, so machen wir das aktuell auch.
Wir haben ein eigenes Terraform-Modul für Kubernetes-Cluster, der installiert,
zart man hat schon so was mit das machen wir auch über terraform an mir gefällt
jedes mal nicht zum beispiel hatte ich letztens was dass ich bei dem engine x
in press oder was schon gateway ich wollte irgendeine option für den
ingress controller setzen es könnte auch gateway api gewesen sein so egal und das
ging dann nicht das war auch ganz aber nicht also ich würde lieber kubernetes
jammel in jammel belassen uns nicht in terraform reinwurschteln muss man gucken
wie es am besten passt
genau ich habe ihn scheitern freundin youtube video gesehen hat es müssen wir
mal zusammen angucken genau hier das und kreativ ecke tschüss windows darum wechsle
ich dieses jahr zu linux das jahr des linux desktops
da bin ich mal gespannt
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin der Meinung, es wird nie das Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben,
sondern, dass es weiterhin so ein schleichender Prozess ist, wie es auch die letzten Jahre über war.
Ja, gerade das letzte Jahr hat das richtigen Knick nach oben im Graph gemacht, was natürlich auch unter anderem daran liegt, dass Microsoft es richtig hardcore immer weiter verkackt unter Windows und dass immer mehr Influencers auf die Linux-Geschichte aufspringen.
und das hat schon einen richtig großen Klick nach oben gemacht das letzte Jahr über, was so die Linux-Verbreitung angeht.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem nicht, dass man sich daran ableiten kann, quasi jetzt wird es jedes Jahr 5% mehr Linux-User geben
und in so und so vielen Jahren sind wir dann alle auf Linux.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, ich gehe davon aus, das wird weiterhin ein langsamer schleichender Prozess sein
und
aber unterm Strich Linux trotzdem auch immer besser machen,
weil es ja oftmals so ein bisschen Henne-Ei-Problem immer war
mit Anwendungen und Sachen unter Linux.
Und ich glaube, das wird zunehmend besser.
Und was wir jetzt natürlich auch noch erwähnen müssen,
ist Valve hat natürlich auch einen riesen Anteil dran,
dass Steam unter Linux funktioniert
und mit Proton auch viele Spiele,
die gar nicht für Linux entwickelt werden,
auch easy funktionieren unter Linux.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, ein springender Punkt, der für viele auch...